[Music]
I now baptize you in the name of where's
your God now peace be with you and also
with me
[Applause]
blessed be the fruit my body my choice
what you gonna do when big-ass baby gets
cranky on you
[Applause]
my body slam you in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
[Applause]
that's one big-ass baby I get excited
every time there's a baptism in my
church anything that shapes seven
minutes off the sermon is a blessing
DeLorean your dates here Oh your
daughter how'd your dad okay guys smile
for the camera
[Music]
I am so wet me too
you need to change
[Music]
that's one big-ass baby let this be a
lesson to all big-ass baby didn't wear a
big-ass condom and now he's got a
big-ass problem
[Music]
excuse me fine between you two
guys kids fly free okay I'm an awful
flyer
this guy's bones not in plane boat hey
this guy's phones not in plane mode oh I
get claustrophobic I can't pop my ears I
can't pop my ears that's one big ass
baby
I was cranky because TSA only lets you
take three ounces of formula through
security and that's not enough for big
ass baby excuse me for a moment
gentlemen okay we have about ten more
minutes
[Applause]
resk bring me my baby no
deal all that Fredrik drop the tape on
first thing in the morning
thank you
[Music]
that's one big ass baby
now the Breaking Bad is over I think we
can all agree big ass baby is the best
show on TV need you to roll down your
window sir I just remembered I've got a
slim jim and ask you to turn that down
sir oh you seem distracted have you been
texting
are you drinking today sir I can't eat
salad so yeah I need you to go ahead and
step out of the car sir
[Music]
factors wet
that is one big-ass baby you know really
loves that reoccurring bit of ours
the writers over that's now
you